all right so since all of you like my
sex game I mean my uh my first game that
I made for latinum dare 24. I did a code
review on it video up there I thought
and correct me if I'm wrong but I
thought it would be a good idea to
remake that game in C plus plus to take
it from the original Java code and
essentially Port it to C plus plus
optimize it fix some bugs show some
different ways of doing things and use
it as like a teaching example to show
you guys how I would even approach
something like that and to hopefully
discuss like some good ways of
essentially remaking this game because
that way instead of looking at like
existing code that other people have
written and then just speculating oh I
would do this I would do that I'm
actually forced to write the code we're
going to actually build this obviously
from scratch because the original code
is in Java and along the way hopefully
in each episode of this series we'll
kind of focus on specific things so that
you don't necessarily need to watch like
every episode and the whole series
unless you want to watch all of it you
can kind of pick and choose choose your
own adventure so for those of you who
missed it this was the original national
game it's a it's called Genesis there's
like a main menu we're gonna remake all
of this like the idea like I'm gonna use
all of these assets we're going to
remake it completely the goal is for you
not to know if you're playing like the
Java version or the Civil plus version
it needs to be the same that's kind of
the point except I might fix some bugs
because I think there's like a lighting
bug but anyway when you hit play
this is uh what happens it loads this
kind of level from a file we can move
around one really important thing to
note is that like the way that this game
actually works is these pixels are all
kind of rendered individually into a
kind of pixel array so this is kind of
like essentially what you would call
software rendering or software
rasterizing because we're doing all of
this on the CPU so instead of kind of
you know uploading these images as
textures to our GPU and getting an API
like opengl or Vulcan or DirectX to
actually draw you know these triangles
and and shade the pixels with like the
colors from the texture and create this
kind of image instead of doing all of
that we kind of maintain like an array
of every single Pixel you see here on
the screen except for text actually
because text is drawn by Java and we'll
get to that later but basically for the
base game we maintain this buffer in
memory which accounts for the color of
every pixel much like a texture and we
write to it every frame in fact we write
to it much more than once per frame
because anytime we want to draw a tile
anytime I want to draw like the main
character or a tree or whatever it may
be we have to basically like get those
pixels from that texture and copy them
across into that buffer and that's how
this kind of image is created while in
the time of me drawing that it got dark
we also have this like nice lighting
going on here where we have like some
torches and you can see it kind of Fades
out almost like Minecraft lighting used
to work back in the day I don't know if
they still do that but um you know we'll
we have that we have I think an animated
like little texture here so all of that
stuff we're gonna basically remake we
have a timer here to be honest I think
like I didn't give this too much thought
I thought before I kind of committed to
this oh and you can see that see that
player kind of getting brighter and
darker as we move in and out that's kind
of cool but when there's other mobs
around it tends to break for some reason
so we'll probably fix that as well
um I was saying I didn't give this too
much thought so like you know one of the
things I just realized yeah there we go
he stayed lit which is bad uh is that we
also have to render text somehow and
text rendering is probably going to be
the hardest part of this project unless
we use like a a just a bitmap font which
basically means we have like a Sprite
sheet or a texture atlas of every single
character we want to render every single
glyph kind of already rasterized into
pixels in that texture and then we can
kind of draw that so we might do
something simple like that so that we
don't have to involve like you know free
type or you know assigned distance field
fonts or anything like that to kind of
um just make this easier
yeah any questions that's the game so
that's what we're gonna start remaking
and the other beautiful thing about this
series that I haven't mentioned yet is
that I have no idea what I'm doing I'm
going to be doing all of this completely
live this is not going to be planned at
all I'm going to sit down hit record and
see what happens so like hopefully it's
not going to be too much of a struggle
but I just think that this way you'll
actually see kind of you know more
realistically how I actually work
through this okay so the first thing I
want to do is
um we're probably not going to spend too
much time today actually looking at the
original code from Genesis because we
need to actually like set up the project
in the first place and get everything up
and running so that's what we'll focus
on today I thought about it and I think
the best way to start is probably to use
walnuts Walnut is this kind of
application framework that I made a
while back there's a video I'll have it
linked up there if you want to kind of
find out some more some more info about
that but basically it's like it's kind
of more or less like an application
framework but it uses Vulcan and I'm GUI
and so the idea is all this UI is kind
of rendered you know on the GPU and it's
kind of more seamless to integrate with
like game engines or if you have other
real-time rendering that you would be
using you know Vulcan 4. now strictly
speaking like you could say we don't
really need this we could honestly do
this in a number of ways but the reason
why I'm going to pick Walnut for this is
there's a few reasons first of all the
presence of UI the presence of I'm gooey
there in the first place is actually
going to be really really useful to us
because that kind of just gives us a
really nice platform to throw up some UI
for debugging or anything we really kind
of want to use while we're developing
the game if we want to like display like
some information you know in the UI if
we want to make some sliders or controls
so that we can adjust things maybe load
certain levels you know dump some
information on the screen that's going
to be really really helpful to us the
other thing is because this is kind of
designed to be used with Vulcan right so
you can seamlessly blend real-time bulk
and rendering I think
what we're going to do is initially we
are still going to kind of write
everything pixel by pixel into that
array just like the original Genesis but
I think maybe it would be cool at the
very end of this to kind of you know
once the game's done to kind of Branch
it off or to make a fork from it and
basically make like a a hardware
accelerated version so we would use
Vulcan to actually make the game we
would actually like render it using
Falcon and shaders and all that stuff on
the GPU rather than kind of software
rasterizing it you know into all these
pixels and then we can kind of compare
that and also see how that transition
would go I think that would be kind of
interesting as well so let me know what
you think of that and so for the time
being the strategy is going to be like
since Walnut has I'm gooey and Vulcan
we're gonna use I'm GUI to basically
draw us an image so we can do like imgui
image right and that's going to just
kind of draw an image inside a window
and this image is going to be a walnut
image that we create and we'll write to
that image basically every frame by
setting our buffer of pixels like into
it so at the end of the day it's going
to be Vulcan that draws the game but
it'll be drawing it as if the game was
just a texture that we update every
frame that's going to be like the
initial strategy this is actually
exactly the same way that my Ray tracing
series works if you've been around my
channel you probably know I have a ray
tracing Series where we're building like
a ray Tracer and that's all kind of
based off of Walnut as well that's
exactly kind of the same way that it
works we basically have let me just go
into Source here we have like our
renderer and that will write pixels into
like this buffer called image data so
you can see that's just like a regular
array and then what will happen is we'll
do image set data and then we just set
that buff up and that's kind of it and
anytime like anything resizes we have to
delete that buffer reallocate it and
then we also kind of recreate the image
with like the new width and height as
well and that's all kind of present
inside Walnut so we can just use that
API and then the other thing with Walnut
is that there is actually a walnut app
template which I just updated just so
that it points to like the latest Walnut
sub module here
um so we can actually just use that like
as a starting point if we want to make
an actual application and you can see
it's very simple all we have to do is
customize like the the pre-mag file and
like change the name from all not up to
like genesis you know and we'll kind of
build it from there before we get into
it I want to thank brilliant for
sponsoring this video brilliant is
honestly a really good resource for all
of you who are learning programming and
also want some help with math because
what it is is an amazing website filled
with many many courses on various stem
topics they have a computer science
section with some Great Courses that can
kind of help you think about programming
in a better way which I think would be
useful to a lot of you who are kind of
watching these videos to to become
better programmers or to learn
programming in the first place and
personally I love using brilliant for
their math course they have some really
high quality math courses on things like
linear algebra or calculus and they make
it super easy to learn and understand
with the way that they kind of show
things visually they give you widgets
you can play with so that you can
actually see the math work and you can
get started for free just go to
brilliant.org the channel just have a
browse yourself off and see if you like
their courses and if you do brilliant
have been nice enough to offer the first
200 of my subscribers 20 off an annual
membership huge thank you to brilliant
as always for sponsoring this video okay
so to set this up really simple just
grab that URL go to a directory on your
computer you can hit Ctrl L to access
this little title bar CMD enter you get
a command prompt already inside that
directory assuming you're on Windows oh
by the way I didn't mention this at some
point during this series I want this
game this new C plus version of the game
to work on Mac and Linux so if you're
not on Windows when it initially use
Windows here but eventually we will be
supporting Mac and Linux because I think
that'll be a really cool kind of part of
the series as well to show how to Port
that to other platforms as well and then
once you have a command prompt over here
just type in git clone hyphen hyphen
recursive and then paste in that URL
over here now you can give it a name as
well which I I suggest you do so I'll
call it Genesis which probably give the
repository a name actually
um
should I call it like genesis 2023 or
Genesis CPP Genesis 2. I'll just call it
Genesis remake how about that and hit
enter
you'll also obviously need git installed
for this which for those of you who
don't know you can just Google git go to
like downloads and just download from
Windows and install it and then that
kind of recursive clone the reason we
did that is because we have a bunch of
sub modules that we also want to check
out such as the third party libraries
like gel wglm and imgui as well as well
Walnut is kind of a sub module of this
as well so if you just clone the
template you're not even going to get
walnut so make sure you have that
recursive in there and now we basically
have our Genesis remake and we have that
entire kind of Walnut app template in
here as well so it says if we read the
getting started which I wrote but to be
honest it was like nine months ago so I
don't really remember
um so we can customize pre-make5 lure
and okay and the one inside Walnut app
as well to our liking so we can change
the name from Walnut app to something
else and then run setup.bat and then
it's in there okay cool so let's start
by I guess modifying these files I'm
just going to open them with Visual
Studio code all right
um so instead of Walnut app let's call
this Genesis remake I'll just call it
Genesis I don't think this needs but
like the the repository will be called
Genesis remake because I actually
already have the Genesis repository I
probably should have mentioned that if
you just go to my GitHub page and go to
like repositories you'll see everything
here
um you know that I've talked about such
as the Walnut app template but I'll have
that linked anyway Walnut
um and then you'll also see
don't look through most of the stuff
it's very old and terrible but here's
Genesis right so this is that base code
so what I was showing you guys inside of
Clips here the actual Java code that
stuff is all available here you can just
clone it for yourselves and check it out
so that's like the starting point we're
going to be using
um okay so back in here I'll just call
it Genesis yeah so for that reason
that's why I can't call Genesis because
it's already a repository called Genesis
so I'm going to call Genesis remake
um we'll include uh so the start project
will be
um Genesis and we'll include Genesis and
that can remain the same so what that
means is that um Walnut app we have to
rename two Genesis because we're
including kind of this directory which
will uh kind of include the
pre-make5.lure file inside that
directory and we'll call that Genesis so
basically workspace is like your
solution so we're calling the whole kind
of solution Genesis but then there's
also a project inside the solution
called Genesis as well as Walnut um and
so that will be Genesis and this Remains
the Same yeah everything here I think
basically remains
the same we don't really need to touch
anything so hopefully if we go back and
into scripts if we double click on
setup.bat that should just generate all
of those project files including our
kind of Genesis Project file inside the
Genesis directory as you can see and so
the idea is Walnut is kind of like the
the engine almost like the base library
that remains here but then Genesis is
our actual game and you can see there's
a vcx project here as well and the
solution file is in the root of the
repository the root directory of your
project um Okay cool so inside Genesis
we have Walnut app and I guess the first
thing we can do is just build it see if
it runs I'm just going to hit this
button up here green button go and it
will compile I'm GUI and Jill FW and
walnut and everything basically and it
will run it and this is what we get okay
so we have like a couple Windows you can
even drag them out which is pretty cool
um we have this like uh you know
resizable window which even has a file
exit that closes
um our game and that's what it says here
now obviously like this by itself does
not really look like a game and we're
going to talk about this probably later
in the series but I just thought it
would be easier to kind of start from
this if that makes sense because this
will kind of cut down all the
boilerplate code and we can actually get
to you know where we need to go faster
because at this point you can see how
quick that setup was I can basically
start making the game now
um but realistically later on what we're
going to probably want to do is get rid
of this like I'm gooey doc space
basically so that we can actually render
like directly to the window ourselves
and then have iron GUI as like a
separate thing on top of that if we
decide that we need it and that way we
can also cut it out of the release build
that we distribute because the other
goal with this series is I want to
actually kind of ship this game like
I'll release it to you guys like on hio
or something so you can download and
play like the finished product on
Windows Mac and Linux that's that's the
goal and so for that I obviously like
don't need imgui at all we just want it
like during development and even though
we're doing all the kind of software
rendering ourselves we still need a way
to kind of have Vulcan draw all like a
full screen quad or full screen triangle
or whatever and like get those picks
they'll probably have to like write a
Shader for that maybe we could just
blend it directly onto a swap chain
image instead I don't know but we'll
investigate that like at the end for now
we're just gonna basically make the game
be an image inside one of these windows
which we can just happily dock here
we'll get rid of the I'm GUI demo then
you can see we basically have the game
like inside this window that's going to
be my first strategy because that's just
gonna be the easiest thing to do
speaking of which let's rename Walnut
app to be called Genesis app uh and then
let's see so we we don't want the menu
bar at all so we can just get rid of
that
um we I don't know if we need it
realistically maybe it will be good to
spawn some debug Windows whatever we'll
add it back if we need it and then
example layer I'm going to just rename
that to be I guess game layer because
this for like from here it's basically
going to be like our whole game is going
to stem from here we're not going to
touch this function anymore apart from I
guess the title we'll change it to be
called Genesis but that's kind of done
everything's going gonna come from here
and it's a walnut layer which has a
whole bunch of whoops
it's a walnut layer which has a whole
bunch of different functions that we can
override such as unattached detach on
update and UI render so on update it's
going to be important because that's
what we're going to do all of our
rendering basically and on UI render is
just going to render any debug windows
we need and also like our kind of main
game viewport now I'll just call it game
so we'll have game here and our goal is
going to be to basically render an IM
GUI image
so for today as I mentioned we're not
going to probably look at this Java code
too much I think my plan is just going
to be to basically uh just get like an
image up on the screen we're going to
try and have this be like
a bit more bite-sized these episodes
um so that we can uh you know not have
huge 40 minute
long episodes I don't know do you guys
enjoy like those long videos or would
you rather have more frequent bite-sized
videos
um I think it might just be easier
because if we focus on certain things
you know certain specific things in
certain videos like people that might be
more helpful to people so if they want
to like know how to I don't know render
some pixels from a texture onto a thing
or whatever that's just that episode
instead of like it being you know one
part of an episode where we do like 50
different things if that makes sense uh
so I don't know we'll see
um so what was it on update float TS but
do we need that no well actually I guess
what I wanted
um was on attach because on attach is
kind of like our Constructor
um the difference between the
Constructor and on attach there's not
much uh there's a crucial difference
though you can see that if I just had a
Constructor here
that just like created stuff like for
example I wanted to create an image the
problem with that is that uh if you look
at when this Constructor gets called
it's going to get called on this line
over here
right so when we do Walnut application
uh over here and we create oh no it's
not sorry it's going to get created here
maybe that's fine then yeah it probably
is fine because it calls on attached
anyway
um the the reason why I was a bit
hesitant here is because you can see
application init
will actually like create the window and
it'll also kind of uh you know create
our Vulcan instance and loading an image
or creating an image is going to involve
Vulcan and so we have to be careful
because if we try and do that before
this line which wouldn't be the case in
the Constructor but if we did then that
would mean that
um that wouldn't work because what
Vulcan doesn't exist yet we haven't
really created Vulcan but here we are
trying to create an image with Vulcan uh
so that's just something you need to be
aware of like the kind of order of
initialization will matter but again
here if we actually look at the code we
know that Walnut application The
Constructor here will call in it inside
the application class and it will kind
of create all the Balkan stuff
initialize all that stuff and so when we
do our push layer game layer you can see
what that will do is because you're
doing SCD makes shared with t and t is
game layer you're basically you know
you're creating a shared pointer from
this game layer class which is going to
call the Constructor and therefore
that's fine so in this case it doesn't
actually matter I guess I can just do it
inside the Constructor to make it a bit
more easy maybe to understand but again
it doesn't matter
because they're going to happen at the
same time because you can actually see
in push layer that as soon as we create
this and then place it back we call on
attach immediately so it's really not
going to matter
um okay so if we do uh image equals now
image so let's look at the image class
so Walnut image is a class that comes
with Walnut which is just supposed to be
like a really nice kind of helper for
um us to to basically create like images
or Textures in Vulcan so you can see
what it does is there's a couple
Constructors here there's one that takes
in a path like a file path and there's
one that takes in
width height and image format and a
pointer to some data so this is the one
we're interested in because we'll be
kind of bringing our own data we don't
want to load an image at this stage from
disk eventually we will we will want to
because we want to obviously load all
the textures by the way I didn't really
quite mention that but there are like
this does include
um you know all of the assets that we
have here such as this that's a terrible
look at this level design I was just
like yeah that's hilarious just give me
a level there's a lot of day you know
made in like what 20 hours I think I
made this this game in or something like
that
um
but I think uh ocean is the name yeah
see so we're gonna reuse that obviously
and then sprites.png is also a Sprite
sheet that I made so here's the player I
remember I had the player as like very
big first but then I was like that looks
stupid so I made him not that big
um and this is also a bit stupid because
I could have just programmatically
changed the green to be pink so maybe
we'll do that actually and then there
was this lion oh this is all coming back
to me there was like a lion that I made
that I didn't use ah this is kind of
cool and then you can see here are the
tiles so there's like some grass and
like some flowers some rocks you know
the torch the the trees
um the snow trees for the snow map and
the snow tiles for the snow map and then
this kind of there's two of these
because it's kind of an animation that
it flips between these two and that's
ice over here uh some kind of very
stupid looking Rock here
um so basically uh yeah this we will
um we'll use all of the original assets
which I think will be kind of cool
um and then also yeah you can see that
we have the pink here because uh this is
kind of like transparent like these
colors are going to be when we copy the
pixels of this of this kind of cell into
our array we will not copy the pixels
that are of that color thereby kind of
creating blending in a way well not
really blending we're just discarding
those pixels uh there's no actual
blending like there's no blending would
be if you have something that's
partially transparent you know
translucent and you blend it with what's
existing kind of already in that base
buffer that you're writing to which we
do none of that because everything here
is either opaque or completely
transparent
um but yeah we'll be using that uh and
obviously the original levels because
why would we want to make better ones
um so that's going to be funny but uh so
we will need to eventually you know load
uh images from file which is fine
because it will not support that
um but for now let's go ahead and try
and do SCD make a shed uh we'll do
Walnut image I'm not gonna like using
namespace well not here I think and we
might actually end up bringing this out
we probably should end up bringing this
out into its own file but let's first
make the image so what's the width and
height of this image so we kind of want
it to be the width and height of
whatever window we render to this is
again very similar to the ray tracing
series and the setup we did there so I'm
going to kind of speed through this
um but this should be self-explanatory I
think so when we make it
um I mean is there even any point in
making it here I don't know I mean we
want to render it here so we could
probably just lazy kind of load it we
could say that if if the image doesn't
exist
um which we haven't even made the image
actually so let's just grab
STD uh shared pointer or not image image
we could say if the image doesn't exist
we'll make it here
um and then we have to make it with
whatever the kind of width and height is
going to be so this is all kind of this
is already getting a little bit
confusing unfortunately because we need
the image to dynamically to resize
um so it's not as straightforward but I
guess let's kind of do this I'm going to
try and do this in a way that doesn't
confuse too many people too quickly so
first let's make let's just make an
image that's going to be 960 by 540
I mean technically speaking the original
Genesis did actually have a fixed window
size you can't resize it but I figure
I don't know do we keep that or do we
not drop a comment below as to what like
how close that I should match this
original game should I make it resizable
I think I probably should because it'd
be nice to just make this full screen
and play it full screen right like you
know
we might as well like add some
improvements to it like along the way
but
um
if if it wasn't I guess it would
technically be easier because we could
just hot card basically everything but
let's not do it that way for now at
least so 960x540 is an example um and
then we'll do image formats
uh RGB a
rgba we don't need rgba 32f
um okay so that's our image uh and then
what I want to do is we can so to draw
it we can just do image get descriptor
set and then set like a size so we can
set a size to be ninth well let's do
image get size I'll get width image get
height
uh and we can I think that's gonna
return like a uint so we can cast it to
a float to avoid any uh warnings from
the compiler add the little Kelly
bracket at the end which is
oh no no hang on sorry not Kelly bracket
I used an old parenthesis for the
Constructor here uh and that's kind of
it so let's maybe try running that I
wonder what will happen here yeah okay
we'll just get a black uh screen so if
we grab this looks like we've got some
kind of invalid image layout oh well
yeah because we haven't written anything
to this so one of the things we should
do is we've set no data here so what I
want to do is I'm going to create an
array like we have inside
um here kind of so if we look at the
screen class inside the Java you can see
that I create this kind of array here of
integers called pixels so we're
basically going to do that the only
difference is we're going to have here
uh we're going to make it a un32t
pointer instead of a just a normal int
which is what the Java one had the
reason being that I think Java doesn't
have unsigned integers or at least it
didn't back then in like Java 1.6 or
whatever this was written in
um so
uh yeah I mean I prefer to work with
unsigned uh integers when we're dealing
with like pixels but again fundamentally
doesn't matter the data is kind of the
same at the end of the day but this just
is better for me uh well and we'll call
it image data and we'll make it a
pointer and we'll set it to null pointer
because we need to this also needs to
kind of be the size of our image so for
example in this case when we create it
we know it's 960 by 540 so we can kind
of just create that and we're done and
now this holds because it has that many
integers in it each integer is going to
be one color for one pixel right so if
we go through uh you know that whole
array for example 960 by 540 like this
we can make it Pink by basically just
doing image outer I equals and then the
color now it's going going to basically
be our
r g b a as far as I'm aware so the most
significant bits here are going to be
the alpha Channel and then we're going
to have blue green and red that's kind
of the way I believe it's gonna work
um so it's kind of not it's not like
rgba it's a BGR
because we kind of that's because the
bytes are flipped it's almost like a
little end in big Indian kind of thing
um so the least significant bits are
going to be the red Channel I believe
so what that means and again it won't
really matter for this as long as you
don't get your Alpha mixed up because
you won't know which one's red and blue
because they're the same
um but if we try and now basically take
the image and set its data so set data
to be image data
right alternatively we could of course
bring this down and then instead of
doing that just
put image data into here right um we're
going to have to set data every frame
anyway but we'll do this for now you can
see we get a nice pink
um window here now it will always remain
960 by 540 it looks like it would still
ask some validation errors to do with a
nice trophy uh this might be some Walnut
stuff which I might do outside of this
series but basically um we kind of have
our game view as you can see and it's
this now the problem with this though is
that again it's not the right size we
want it to resize so what that means is
that we kind of need to maintain like
the size of this now you can ask uh I am
gooey
what the size of the window is
um if you do get content region
available
uh I know I believe they deprecated some
stuff I think it was men and Max's uh
like with and yeah so that should be
fine get content region available and
then X is going to basically be the the
width so if we just do like window width
equals that
which will cost to you on 32 tick
because I think this returns a float
um and window height
we can basically just check to see
whether or not they match the size of
the image so if window width doesn't
equal
um
M image gets
with or so if either of them are
different doesn't equal if window height
doesn't equal image
get height
then we know that it needs to be updated
so we can basically say okay well you
know what image
um why don't we recreate you with
whatever the width and height actually
is
um and then
uh we'll have to also recreate image
data so we'll delete it first so that we
like
um you know free that memory
and then we'll create it like we did
here but this is going to be
window width window height
maybe I should have called it window
because well it is this window but it's
not the whole window it's just this I'm
GUI window
um what's your problem I'm using all
part number four byte value can results
Ah that's
that's the stupidest thing ever that's
saying that this can result in a value
greater than
that 32-bit integer so therefore you
should like cast it or whatever
so what it wants me to do this isn't
that just like
isn't that just
imagine that no we're gonna we're gonna
say no to that
um okay and then we'll have to well we
should be setting the data every frame
really so let's maybe say that before we
do this or actually it will be
technically done in update
um we can kind of
you know maybe we should even have an L
so we skipped that frame or is that
going to be weird if we skip that frame
the problem is that we react to the
resize here
um but then we probably will want to set
the data inside our update not that it
really matters like if you were to look
at uh application I guess to just see
where this stuff's called you can see
the left this is called here
as like the first thing really uh in in
the entire frame because here's the
while loop we call this here but then on
UI render is probably called in like the
doc space
over here right and so
what does that mean
um that means so it's called a bit later
this is it being called up here first
thing in the frame this has been called
down here uh inside
here right
um so the problem here that we need to
think about is
if we go ahead and say let's basically
delete the image because we're you know
recreating that shared pointers is going
to delete the old one as long as I don't
know other references to it then we kind
of have to think about well do we
immediately display that image if the
game hasn't rendered to it yet or do we
then get the game to render to it here
basically or the game to kind of you
know set its pixels into this Vulcan
texture here and then we draw around
which I guess we could do
like we're gonna say okay well if the
window is suddenly a different size then
recreate this do the image data and
since you've just done that then maybe
you could do image
set data image data
I guess that would be fine no actually
it wouldn't be because we just created a
blank array here of garbage probably
especially if it's not initialized and
then we're setting that here so that's
going to be
we need the game to actually populate it
again this is an example of the game
populating it
um
so I don't know
it's getting tricky episode one
and it's already a struggle
um yeah I don't know
I don't know because my ideal way to do
this would probably be like that but the
problem is that if we then
see that it's different here then we
react to it immediately you know
um but I probably don't want to do that
in which case we could just
but we can't not render that whole image
I say we almost want to render the
old one so how about we just do but we
don't know the width and height yeah
that's why doing the resize here
reactively is kind of dangerous
the other option to be firm is we could
just do it here
so we draw the image at the old width
and height and then we're like no that's
not gonna work oh
no maybe it will
because I think the image Destructor
will call release which yeah you can see
I write a little submit resource free so
it won't actually delete the texture
from GPU memory until after it's drawn
it so that actually will work
so I think that'll be okay
so hopefully you guys can kind of see my
thought process as I go through all of
this I'm really trying to talk out loud
a lot and uh in as much detail as
possible so let me know if that's
if that's good
um okay so let's just run this and see
what happens I'm a bit scared
okay that worked
I think that's working
as you can see we can resize it we can
drag this out like everything seems to
be working and it's always going to be
the size of the window it's hard to tell
now if it's like stretching or whatever
but because it's just all one color
um but I'm sure it's probably working uh
the last thing we can do is try and
randomize it out of a bit because at
this point we can't see whether or not
it's changing every frame so what we
could do is just use a random
um
you know random uint or something uh
inside the Walnut random
class
which we have to include
and if we do that it should just
scramble it to like a random color
basically every frame as you can see I
probably want to run it run it in
release mode if we're doing that because
that's a decent amount of pixels that
we're randomizing here it'll be fine in
release mode but in debug like it can be
slow so you just want to watch out for
that
um but it's probably not going to be
this slow when we eventually deal with
it okay cool so that's kind of working
that looks good to me
um what else can we tackle here oh yeah
okay so if you look in if you look at
our window here you can see there's like
this black border right it matches
because I'm going to have some window
padding by default so what we can do is
before we actually begin the window we
can do I am gooey push style VAR I am
going uh style for window padding and
then I am back to
you know zero zero and so that's just
gonna basically set the padding to zero
and then at the end we have to pop it so
Pop Style Bar
and that will just get rid of that
padding so that it's nice and you can
see there's no border now it's nice that
it's like exactly at the end
um
I feel like there was something else I
wanted to do
or is that a good first episode I don't
know oh yeah scaling I wanted to kind of
talk about scaling because remember this
game has a scale so basically what
happens here is every pixel that we have
here is actually scaled up like I think
by three so every pixel is actually a
three by three pixel and the reason why
is because inside game you can see we
have like this pixels array but the
width and height is actually 300 by you
know whatever that is 180 300 by 180 but
then the scale is three because what
we're doing is we're actually like
scaling it up by three if it wasn't
scaled up if it wasn't like you know
upsized the actual image and we had like
say 900 because that's what it would be
you can see everything's gonna look like
super small like that if you hit play
you can almost see like the whole island
um and we kind of get that you know
retro look by having low resolution
Graphics but scaling them up and that's
obviously very important to maintain so
the way we would do that
um and to be honest we're probably going
to have to go into the sampler and
actually change some things but the way
we would do that is we would have a
scale
u132t image scale we could set that to
like three
and then if we come over here when we
make the image this doesn't really
matter we honestly don't even kind of
need to do that uh it'd probably be
worth not doing that but when we do this
we want to basically do window width
divided by the image scale and window
height divided by the image scale right
and same with this so it's going to be
window width divided by image scale and
window height divided by image scale so
the critical thing here is that each
like Dimension is being divided by the
image scale so it's not like the overall
pixels are being you know divided by
three it's the width and the height
being divided by three which is kind of
why we put it in both of these not just
at the end so that's done uh now that so
basically the the difference here though
is window width and height
um they're not going to be scaled
they're going to be the actual like real
width and height so we need to kind of
make sure that if we go down that route
we also divide these by three so that
they match this otherwise this
comparison is always going to be wrong
and probably to reflect like that I
might rename this to be scaled window
width and scaled window height because
otherwise it might be a bit confusing as
to what I don't know if we have divided
by three here uh and then but but the
difference is that when we draw the
image which actually I already changed
well no where do we draw the image here
when we draw the image we do times scale
right so we're drawing the we're kind of
stretching the image making it larger
than it actually is but the image
daughter itself is Tiny kind of like
this okay we need to also make sure that
yeah this so this is already the scaled
one so the scaled one we obviously don't
divide by three my mistake because
otherwise we're applying that scale
twice which is why we saw such a tiny
image and there you go right so what
happens here is we have a very blurry
uh image but you can see it's been
scaled up and the reason why it's blurry
is just because we're using a linear
filtering kind of function I guess it's
basically like in when it scales up and
it needs to create obviously more pixels
out of like the ones it has it looks at
the neighboring pixels and it kind of
Blends between them in a linear way in
the interpolation that's why we get that
kind of blurry look if we wanted to
remain sharp kind of like Minecraft
textures then we need to use nearest
filtering or Point filtering it's
sometimes called as well
um so to do that we like if we to get
really like uh deep here if we actually
go to application the reason why it's
using linear filtering is because we've
told it to use linear filtering so if we
go into
uh oh actually would that be does the
image ship with its own sampler
I don't remember where this is yeah
create sampler so you can see that in
the in the image in the Walnut image we
created we set its sampler to be linear
for the magnification and the
minification so if we changed this to be
nearest
um and really magnification is kind of
what we're after here because we're
making it bigger we're magnifying it
then okay it's still blurry yeah because
I wouldn't have expected it to be here I
don't even know what this sample is used
for
um but no but we do add this texture
when we create the descriptor set so I
just have a feeling that it uses its own
sampler like I'm Google uses their own
sampler when they draw that because that
unless I was stupid there but I'm pretty
sure yeah that's definitely linearly
interpolated maybe next episode would be
a good opportunity to show how I would
approach debugging like a little
rendering Graphics issue like this but
anyway let me know what you thought of
this kind of first episode of this new
series hopefully you enjoyed the format
and we can kind of have some fun just
chill out and have a good time thank you
guys for watching don't forget to check
out brilliant using my link in
description below and I will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you